foreign
[Music]
strength is beauty beauty is strength
What Makes You Beautiful She-Hulk by
Titania
this is the person who legally
outmaneuvered you
yeah
why didn't you trademark your own
pseudonym why would I uh did Doctor
Strange have to trademark his name did
Thor you chose two examples of people
who use their real names
I'm still Jennifer Walters She-Hulk is
just a thing that happened to me you
said you didn't like the name I don't I
do admit though there are parts of it
that I enjoy
the amazing hair no hangover
being able to walk home at night without
being afraid
[Music]
input on your green suit put on my green
suit yeah jelly green yourself I don't
know what you call it hulking out okay
good whatever
trouble's gonna find you weird
unexpected trouble
[Music]
I'll be right back
life would be so much easier if I was
just jet if I think you're in a unique
position to do some real good Jen
Walters can use the law to help people
when Society fails and she all can help
people when the law fails this guy's
really kind of doing it for me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
cause you're gonna take it for texting
just say you were texting 9-1-1 they
can't prosecute that isn't what this is
and that's not true
[Music]